بلد المنشا انصحها التعبير لاحدى اكبر
الكوارث الصحيه الحديثه طبعا وفقا
للالاتهامات رفع معظم القيود الخاصه
بكرونا وتهيا لازالتها تماما بعد سبعه
ايام لكن رحله السنوات الثلاث الماضيه لم
تكن سهله على الصين التي تاثر قطاعها
الصحي وكذلك الاقتصادي وهذا ما اقر به
رئيس هيئه لاول مره بحسب صحيفه وول ستريد
جورنا الاكدتشي التمسك بالامل واصفا
تحولات السياسه الوبائيه بانها محاوله
للتكيف مع الفيروس المتطور وقابليه
الانتقال العاليه غير انها القيود وعمليات
الاغلاق والحجر الصحي الاجباري اغرقت
مستشفيات الصين بعشرات الالاف من المصابين
واثقلت كاهله قامها الطبي مجددا مع بقاء
الارقام الرسميه المعلنه دون الواقع
باصوات قله شفافيه هذه وايضا افتقار بكين
المعلومات الشامله حول عدد الاصابات عاد
مسافرين الصينيين لمربع كورونا الاول اي
بدايه عام 2020 المسافرون من الصين وجهون
قيود عند دخول اكثر من 12 بلد من بينها
الولايات المتحده نتحدث ايضا عن فرنسا
وايطاليا مجددا تقديم اختبارات سلبيه
مطلوبه منهم قبل الوصول الى مطاراتها او
الخضوع لاختبار عند الوصول فيما اعلن
المغرب حضره دخول المسافرين القادمين من
الصين على اراضيه اعتبارا من الثالث من
يناير لتجنب موجه جديده من العدوى
بالفايروس والحمايه من متحورات محتمله
وصفات منظمه الصحه العالميه هذه الاجراءات
الاحترازيه بانها مفهومه في نقص المعلومات
حول الموجه الحاليه من الوباء بكيا
[موسيقى]